[Music]
okay
we do
Oh
[Music]
Wow
that was fun wasn't it good afternoon
hello hello everyone all right
I am Poornima coach a car and my team
has the privilege of working with apps
and games developers globally the
animation you just saw is inspired by
the amazing content you create which
gives people superpowers and helps us
move the mobile ecosystem forward thank
you Before we jump into what's new on
Google Play let's take a moment to look
back at the amazing growth we have seen
since we met at i/o a year ago you heard
at the keynote that Android and play are
being used by increasing number of users
around the world Android is now active
on 2 billion devices monthly and an
astounding 82 billion apps have been
installed from Google Play in the last
12 months
this is translating into more developers
finding success on Google Play in the
last year alone the number of developers
with more than 1 million installs grew
by 35% this is phenomenal and makes me
truly happy give yourselves a very big
hand
we are also investing to enable everyone
to pay for your apps and games using
forms of payment that they prefer for
example Americans prefer credit cards
Japanese prefer DCB and Germans prefer
PayPal and Brazilians before some kind
of a prepaid method like gift cards
which gives them control over their
payments these sheer scale of our
payment platform that you see behind me
continues to amaze me as a result we are
seeing that increase number of people
paying for your apps and games than ever
before in the last year alone the number
of new buyers on play grew by 30% in
particular we are seeing great traction
for the subscription business model the
number of subscribers grew by 2x last
year with 62% of the subscribers telling
us that they use their app at least once
a day
beyond payments they are also investing
in capabilities to help you reach more
users in more ways the Play Store is now
available on trading VR and on
Chromebooks that allows you to reach
users in interesting new ways last year
at i/o we previewed android instant apps
this allows your users to get access to
your apps without the hurdle of having
to install the app we are very grateful
to many of you I can see you in the
audience here who worked with us to make
that vision a reality
and today we open up Android infant apps
to everyone I hope you will all start
working on them
beyond our sorry and yesterday we we
previewed Android gold which is our
optimized version of Android for
emerging markets devices as you know
there are billions of people in emerging
markets were coming on to mobile for the
first time please take the time to look
at the building for billions guidelines
to help you build for these devices
above all we are taking into account
quality in every decision we are making
on the Play Store through programs like
early access we are bringing you
dedicated and highly motivated 23
million-plus people who are willing to
test your apps and give you feedback
well they are still in development
before you put it up for production we
are engaging with Indies around the
world to find the best quality games and
they're showcasing them on the indie
corner and we are also taking into
account engagement in all our algorithms
that shape our top charts and today this
evening we will host the second annual
Google Play Awards we will be
celebrating the best of the best
acknowledging great quality in apps and
games I hope to see you there please
come be inspired and come to celebrate
what makes great apps and games so just
as your apps are giving people
superpowers of engineering and product
teams are working on capabilities to
give you the superpowers to succeed on
Google Play so are you ready to see what
they've been cooking you can do better
than that all right put your hands
together for Matt Henderson group
product manager
[Applause]
right thanks for NEMA hi everybody so in
your organization
who else besides you cares about the
success of your app who else contributes
to the success of your app a lot of
people write in a variety of roles will
have a think about who else in your
organization should be using the play
console when we started the console five
years ago was a means to get an app from
A to B from developer to the phone but
over the years it's become much more
than that with a variety of users and
variety of features the play console is
playing a much broader role in the
success of your app with more features
the user base has brought in two
different roles in your organization our
users now our product managers their
marketing managers their test engineers
and of course their Android developers
so think about who else in your
organization should be using the play
console now with that growth in the
variety of features UI design needs to
keep things organized so in addition to
talking about features today I wanted to
touch on the UI look and feel of the
console you may have noticed some
changes we've launched a new cleaner and
clearer material design based play
console and it has a new name the Play
Developer console is now just the play
console this reflects the fact that
although all of your organization's
develop apps not all of you are
developers the user base is getting more
and more diverse as we're playing a more
diverse role in the success of your app
an early feedback about the UI suggests
were on the right track
such as this from the e-commerce app
Zalando the redesigned play console is
more intuitive it's more structured it's
more convenient but of course in
addition to a new design we've been hard
at work with new functionality so here
are some highlights of launches from the
past 12 months there's been features to
help app quality like beta testing and
the pre-launch report there's new tools
to manage the release process there's
also new reporting and pricing features
to help you identify and take advantage
of opportunities to grow your business
and now at this i/o we're announcing
important new and updated features in
all of these areas that go even further
at helping you create high-quality app
experiences they go even further helping
you mitigate risk in the release process
and they go even further in helping you
to achieve business success now I'm
going to hand over to some more of the
team to give you a snapshot of each of
these different features starting with
Fergus Park manager from the play team
in London
[Applause]
thanks man who here wants to know the
secret to get a five-star app on Google
Play
all right great came to the right talk
we did machine learning overall the
Google Play reviews and what we found is
that 50% of all the one star reviews are
talking about stability issues so if you
want to increase your star rating and
reduce the number one star ratings for
your app the number one thing you can do
is focus on stability of your
application okay then once you fix those
stability issues what you do is to be
able to increase your star rating to
golden 5 stars
well you focus on design usability and
speed yesterday in the keynote you might
have seen Android BIOS
this is our initiative at Google to help
you be able to understand the
performance and stability of your
applications we've had hundreds of
millions of users who've opted in to
share their device diagnostics and usage
data with Google so that we can be able
to help partners like you be able to
provide better experiences we're now
giving you that data in an aggregate
fashion so you can be able to understand
your performance we're starting with
free performance areas stability battery
and rendering we're going to be
expanding to many more over the course
of the next year and so stay tuned and
for those now as we expand to more and
more performance areas there's a lot of
data to be able to understand how do we
simplify it for you
well we're introducing this concept of
bad behaviors bad behaviors are when
your ass falls in the lowest 25% of apps
for that metric and if you are in the
lowest 25% we'll flag you as being in
the lowest 25% and you'll be able to
understand that you should prioritize
fixing your app in that area so the
first area is stability this is all
about providing a robust and stable
experience to your users that is
reliable there are two performance areas
to performance metrics within this area
the first is your a and or race or
application not responding race this is
when you're asked freezes for more than
five seconds
second area is crash rate this is when
your application as it closes on the
user the second performance area is
battery so this is where your app is
using the radios or the CPU
unnecessarily and the two performance
metrics that we're focused on here are
stock way clocks this is where you hold
a wakelock for more than an hour when
the device is supposed to be idle and
the second one is wake up this is where
you're waking up the device more than
ten times per hour when the device is
idle the third performance area is
rendering so this is providing users
with that silky smooth experience on
their device so that they feel like your
app is responsive and fluid the two
areas that we have in this metric are
slow rendering so this is when 50% of
your frames take more than 16
milliseconds to render so you're not
achieving that 60 frames per second the
users expect from their device and the
second one is frozen frames this is
where 0.1 percent of your frames take
more than 700 milliseconds to be
rendered this is where users can
actually really feel that there's a lag
and application both of these are shown
in the Play Developer console alongside
all the other bad behaviors as I
mentioned so you can go to the Play
Developer console as of right now and
you can be able to see this data for
your application and then you can be
able to focus on improving those core
metrics for each one we provide links to
developer.android.com which gives you
help articles of how you can be able to
fix these issues yourself finally and if
you don't care about your star rating
which I'm sure most of you do we also
have other reasons why you should care
about this performance area we're
starting to use this performance data in
the promote ability in this store itself
and other things that we're going to
talk about later on today at 5:30 and in
a talk on the top 10 things and to
improve the stability of your
application as you can be able to learn
more about how we're improving the Play
Store to be able use this performance
data now talk a lot about the field data
Android boil I'm going to welcome
Ricardo on stage is going to talk about
how you can be able to understand the
performance of your application before
you launch it thank you
hi everyone it's great to be here today
today I want to talk to you about the
play
clearance report the pre-launch report
summarizes issues that are found when
testing Europe against a wide range of
devices we launched it last year in the
play console and you can find it clear
today padrone's report actively
contributes to the success of apps and
already thousands of you already using
it to create better apps and I want to
mention a few updates that we have about
it the key aspect of pre-launch report
is apt stability testing we use a robot
crawler to automatically test every
appliqud that you upload to alpha or
beta channels in the Play console
against several physical Android devices
the robot tells you if it encounters any
crush during a five-minute roll which
means that you can then fix the crash
before a reaches production and your
users will not leave a one-star review
because of that in the past year
pre-launch report has seen great
momentum over 58% of Plato pups have
opted into using it and we have
conducted over 6.5 million
robot crawls across hundreds of
thousands of apks but number that they
like best is not this one but this one
in 85% of the cases when pre-launch
report found a crush the app was not
later push to production which means
that millions of users has not
experienced these crushes that would
have otherwise affected them which is
pretty nice so we continually improve
pre-launch effort to make it even better
for example to allow the robot to
explore more of the app with data that
you control you can now provide test
potentials that the robot will use to
pass through login screens and explore
more of their pre-launch report
automatically scans erupt for
vulnerabilities and privacy leaks using
the knowledge of Google own security
teams over the last year we are the
scans and now we detect over 30
different type of vulnerabilities and
privacy issues from using obsolete
libraries that have known issues to
leaking identifiers prelaunch report
also captures screenshots and videos
during the crawl we improve the way we
capture damning we collect them and we
now take into account the structure of
your app such as the activities
discomposed off and the transitions to
better cluster the screenshots
intelligently and this gives you a
better view at a glance or fire up looks
like across its various parts which is
great for spotting visual
inconsistencies in your app look and
feel but is the one that I like the most
we added new devices to the forum
including the Google pixel running on
Android Oh preview so that means that
without any work you can check out your
app performs on Android oh and be ready
for when it launched when it launches
later this year so you can go and upload
an apk right now to a deploy console
announcing beta and there's a good
chance that by the end of this talk you
get a sense of how your app performs on
Android or or Awards they might take an
hour so this alive for you today I have
the privilege report gives you that
sense of amazing security that other
developers like Clyde emic already
finding on it and I would like now to
introduce onstage James Smith not the
manager on play thank you Thank You Cara
hi everyone as Android developers one of
the most important things you have to
look after is your app signing key
because your app signing key ensures the
security and integrity of your app lost
a compromised keys can be a very serious
issue your private key is required for
signing all versions of your app if you
lose or misplace your key you will not
be able to publish updates to your app
your only option would be to publish a
new app under a new package name and ask
all of your users to move across this
would be obviously a terrible experience
so that's why we're very excited to be
launching Google Play app signing
if you join this program Google Play
will manage your key on your behalf and
sign your app before delivering it to
users it's really easy to get started
first you securely upload your app
signing key to Google Play that means it
is now safe on Google servers and you
don't need to worry about balancing
security and convenience of access to
your key you can even delete it now to
make sure that updates to your app come
from you the authorize developer any new
apks you upload will be signed with an
upload key the Google uses to verify
your identity the upload key can be
reset which avoids the key loss scenario
I described earlier
we've had several partners using Google
Play app signing for a while and the
feedback has been really positive here
Robinhood speaks to the layer of safety
that we've added while the same time all
but eliminating the worry of having lost
or stolen keys now once Google Play
signed your app we can go one step
further and we can provide optimization
services at your request
the first optimization we've decided to
focus on is making apps smaller we know
that developers care about app size
because users do apk size is correlated
with download success and with uninstall
rate looking apks we can see that
developers include native libraries and
different architectures and drawables
for different screen densities so the
apps look and run the best on every
device but this means that a lot of the
contents of an apk is unnecessary for
every device if I have a phone with a
32-bit architecture and a hdpi screen
then I only need the contents of the
boxes in blue in this diagram and the
rest in green is completely unnecessary
from my device
with app optimizations play will deliver
just the right content for each device
you gave us a universal apk and we will
automatically create optimized apks for
different devices we're just getting
started exploring this area and it's
still early but we've tried this out
with apps that were in our early access
program and we expect the average
signing to be about 15% however some
apps have seen better results delivery
was 33% smaller after optimizations and
the seven minute workout app was nearly
a half smaller at 48% so when can you
get these benefits
well AB signing is available today we
are trialing app optimization in beta
with a few partners at the moment and we
hope to widen the beta in the near
future if you are interested in
optimizations please enroll in app
signing to be and if you'd like to find
out more about these topics please come
to a talk at 2:30 this afternoon on
stage one thanks I know like to invite
Mike the engineering manager on Google
Play to talk about device catalog which
is also available today
[Applause]
thanks James so as we saw at the start
of this talk the Android ecosystem is
seeing significant growth and this is in
part due to the diversity of Android
devices with a range of different
capabilities and price points we hear
that you love the reach - this brings
but understanding list of eyespace and
targeting the right devices can
sometimes be a bit of a challenge and so
to help with this we have launched a new
device catalog section in the Google
Play console thank you using everything
that we know about Android we've gone
from this long list of device codes to a
rich full-featured device catalog looks
pretty awesome right so what can this do
for you first of all we provide details
of eye specs including RAM
system-on-chip GPU screen size and OS
version for every one of the thousands
of Android devices that's certified by
Google we also group these devices into
models and allow you to drill down to
understand the variations between them
to help navigate this device space we
provide search and filter options
allowing you to slice and dice the
catalog by various device features for
example you can use this to quickly find
all SDK level 24 devices with the
Snapdragon 810 socks or as you see here
all devices manufactured by Google with
more than 2 Giga RAM and as you may have
noticed this is more than just a VY
specs with any filter we also provide
key metrics for how your app performs on
these devices such as installs average
ratings and revenue in addition to this
we've also introduced another new
feature we call device exclusion rules
this allows you to exclude your app from
a specific targeted set of devices using
key device performance indicators
for example if you're developing a rich
graphics game you could use this to only
target devices with more than a gig of
ram you could also create a rule to
exclude all devices with a particular
system on chip this can allow you to
temporarily prevent deployment of your
app to a specific set of problematic
devices until you can push a fix
whenever you create an exclusion rule we
will always show you which devices will
be excluded
along with installs and revenue metrics
to help you make this important decision
with confidence as you can see space 8
games have found a great way of
incorporating these new device tools to
reduce cost and improve KPIs to hear
more about this new device catalog
feature along with other release
management tools you can check out the
recording of this talk that was
presented yesterday also please swing by
the Play console sandbox area in don't
see where myself and other engineers
from the console are available to give
demos answer questions and hear your
feedback on this or anything else
relating to the Google Play console and
with that I'm going to hand you over to
Suzanne to tell us about even more new
ways we have to help you release with
confidence
[Applause]
thanks Mike and hello well I will walk
you through the release dashboard which
we don't yesterday you want to make sure
that your production release is
successful
we've always been ahead of the curve
with tools to prepare great releases
think about the three launch reports
that Ricardo discussed earlier and our
alpha and beta channels but now we also
give you the data to monitor your
production rollouts
out-of-the-box without the need for an
SDK this data is offered in low latency
and can help you make decisions about
your rollout sooner and with more
confidence let me show you a few
highlights when you push in new release
you obviously care about crashes we give
you absolute numbers as well as crashes
for a thousand devices to put those
numbers in context the default views
shown here offers a comparison between
your current release and the aggregate
of all app versions that you have in
production if something does look off
you can then go straight to the crash
clusters page to see if you introduce
any new crashes releases aren't all
about crashes though you also want to
see ratings and reviews that are
specific to your latest version when the
ratings for your latest version is
significantly lower than that of your
overall rating you may want to start
looking into your one and two star
reviews to see what's going on and
possibly even hold your release but what
if you could also see in-store events
broken down by new installs and updates
this can tell you whether enough users
updated to your new version to push your
rollout on to the next stage and think
about the power of knowing how many
uninstalls came from updated devices are
you losing existing customers because
your latest version isn't performing
well clay has these numbers for you out
of the box
so I encourage you to think about what
makes a healthy relief your crash tool
may warn you if you have a huge spike
your p.m. my panic if your ratings
tanked but what about subtle with
significant changes across metrics would
you ever notice if you didn't see them
all in one place and to empower your
decision-making even further we also let
you compare your relief against a
previous release of your choice this
gives you even more context you don't
only have your crashes and A&Rs
you don't only have the impact that
these are having on your ratings and
then your uninstalls but you can also
see how these metrics compare to a
previous release that you considered
successful all in one place all within
hours of your release starting helping
you minimize the time a battery spends
in production so next time you roll new
version out monitoring with the relief
dashboard it is the new topmost item on
the release management and now over to
Preston engineering manager to talk you
through the new statistics pages thank
you thanks Suzanne hi everyone we've
been hard at work this year addressing
our top requests and play statistics I
think you'll be quite pleased with what
we have to share with you today I'd like
to introduce the new play statistics
page from the snapshot you can start to
see them start to feel the magnitude of
effort we put behind the stats
experience since last i/o right now I'll
briefly touch on just a few of my
favorite features first let's drill down
into date selection as you can see we
still have the preset date ranges but
these presets are not sufficient for all
app and business needs so what we I'm
happy to say that we've added a custom
date range selector to let you choose
the periods that you're most interested
in next we know that many of you
manually compare data in the console
with data from previous time period
we've made that process much simpler by
plotting a comparison time period right
alongside your selected date range this
allows you to easily see period over
period trends that will highlight the
impact of releases marketing campaigns
and even public holidays but time
periods aren't the only thing we want to
compare now in the play statistics page
you can select multiple metrics to
compare at the same time when you can
easily compare related metrics such as
crashes and ratings or installs in
revenue you can start to uncover
relationships in your data that are
specific to your app and to your market
the last thing I'd like to mention is
hourly data we're introducing new hourly
stats to help you understand the
behavior of your app throughout the day
this knowledge will help you as you plan
time-sensitive
events such as releases but to me the
most exciting part about hourly data is
that you won't have to wait until
tomorrow to start to see data for today
I think you'll agree that we've made
play statistics more useful to help you
build successful apps I've only touched
on a few of the things that we've added
I'd like you to come and join us in the
in the sandbox to talk about more with
that I'll hand it over to Tamsin our
business development lead to talk about
user acquisition thank you thanks
Kristen
so once you're confident that your apps
health and performance is optimal you'll
probably want to drive new valuable
users to your app right well in my job I
talk to developers every day and they
tell me how critical it is to understand
how effective their marketing channels
are at acquiring and retaining new and
valuable users they tell me they need
more data to make the right decisions
about where to spend their money and
where to spend their time and effort in
optimizing their growth strategies since
last I own we launched two improvements
to the user acquisition report to make
this area of the console even more
useful for you
now just to remind you the user
acquisition report shows you how many
users go to your store listing page of
those how many people install your app
and of those how many people buy and buy
again so the first improvement was that
we added country to the user acquisition
traffic breakdown and this is really
critical because we want you to expand
and succeed and reach those 2 billion
monthly active Android devices around
the world now this report is great
because it will show you where the
unrealized opportunity is so that you
can prioritize your international
expansion the second improvement is that
we added tiered benchmarks now this lets
you see how your app conversion compares
to similar apps in the same category who
monetize in the same way now this is
available both in the acquisition report
and in the country report it's so it
lets you see obvious areas for
improvement it lets you see areas to
further invest your acquisitions and
lets you celebrate your team success now
I'm pretty confident that most of you
here care about building long term
customer relationships right so today
I'm really excited to announce
two of the sun'll especially for
businesses like yours who have a strong
focus on user retention
it shows retention periods which are
critical metrics for understanding which
channels are bringing you your most
loyal users and this is your retain the
Installer base it shows you the
opportunity to increase retention using
notifications and e-mail or increasing
your app quality so from today you'll be
able to identify which channels are
bringing you your most valuable users
which countries they're coming from and
you'll be able to identify the
opportunity if you have to increase your
install and buy conversions and increase
your user retention now all of these
reports help you optimize your growth
strategies not just the install for long
term business success so regardless of
the way you monetize we have an
acquisition report that can help you
grow your business now if you want to
learn more about this or the release
dashboard or the new statistics page you
should come to stage one at 1:30 right
after this and watch making data on
Google play's work for you so come and
see us now to tell you more about
improvements we've made to reviews I'd
like to welcome back on stage circus
[Applause]
great so I'm back again to help those
people who had their hand up earlier
about trying to get a five star app on
play made radical improvements the whole
ratings interview section on the play
console over the past year
couldn't tell you some of those
improvements we've made and we've just
announced
so one thing we announced at Google i/o
last year was reviews analysis this
enables you to be able to see the topics
that people are talking about in your
reviews on Google Play and prioritize
which topics are having the largest
negative and positive impact on your
rating in the store we've heard from
developers that they are using this to
be able to prioritize their feature
development and we're now expanding to
other languages so you can be able to
understand what people in geographies
that you're have your app available but
you don't speak the language are saying
about your application so the second
most popular language on Play is Spanish
and as of yesterday we now have Spanish
topics available in reviews analysis and
a major market for developers on Play is
Japan so we also now support Japanese
topics this is where we're putting
Google's machine learning to work for
you to be able to understand your users
and what they're saying and limitations
on the Google Play reviews for
developers over the past couple years
has been that when users update their
reviews you were only able to see the
latest update of the review now we're
enabling you to be able to see the full
review history of the reviews that that
user has left for your ass
unless they completely delete the review
this enables you to be able to have a
fluid conversation with your users and
be able to communicate with them
effectively so once you start engaging
with your users and you start responding
to reviews how do you understand if it's
actually working for you well we have
updated rating section this is where we
show you what is the change in rating
for reviews that you've responded to
versus ones you haven't responded to and
what we see is that developers are
seeing major results in improving their
star rating of draft by engaging with
the users because users in general
update their ratings to a positive
rating as a result of engaging with them
finally another improvement may 'king
the reviews there
is the ability to be able to flag
reviews that have passed through our
first level of flying that we do
internally of reviews where if you think
that one of the reviews that is posted
on your app does not match our posting
guidelines and it's been filtered true
then you can be able to flag it and
we'll do another manual review check and
evaluation of that review so we have to
determine if it matches our posting
guidelines and if it doesn't we'll
remove that this has already been rolled
out to a percentage of play developers
and we rolled out to the rest of all
developers over the next couple of
months if you want to learn more about
the secrets at should be able to get a
higher rated app on play and increase
your user retention come to the talk we
have later today at 5:30 to be able to
learn more about it things I talked
about in android vitals earlier things
Ricardo mentioned in the pre-launch port
and these ratings topics that I just
talked about I'd like to welcome Tom
who's the product manager on Google Play
come on stage now to talk about
subscriptions
good afternoon everyone I'm super
excited to be here so let's just imagine
for a second that you guys have used all
the great tools that you've heard about
over this i/o and you've worked with
your team and you've made awesome apps
how do you monetize them
well we think one of the best ways to do
that is to use subscriptions on Google
Play one of the reasons we think that
it's because subscriptions are growing
stratospherically we heard from
tournament earlier on that the number of
active subscribers on Play has doubled
in the last year alone that's great but
it's only one data point for a long term
trend in fact consumers spend on
subscriptions on Play has gone up ten
times in the last three years that's an
amazing opportunity for developers like
you to make more money more regularly
and more reliably and I'm going to go
out on a limb and say that that probably
sounds pretty good to quite a lot of you
and quite a lot of us at Google have
been trying to help you have been really
working to power your subscription
businesses so today I'm going to share a
few of the slew of new features of subs
that we're launching our i/o this year
these are features to help you guys now
we know that to run a successful
subscription business you need really
good data so I'm really happy to say
that earlier this week we launched a
brand new part of a play console the
subscriptions dashboard the sub
dashboard pulls together key metrics and
information about your subs business and
puts it all in one place
so at a glance you can see your total
number of subscriptions your new
activations and your cancellations your
daily and your 30 day rolling revenue
and even your top performing subs this
is a great area to get an overview of
how well you're doing it's brilliant if
you want to spot trends or identify
anomalies
and when you do identify an anomaly
you're going to want to know more you're
going to want to know even better data
and for that over the coming weeks we're
launching three brand new click-through
reports each tailored to a key part of
your subscription lifecycle the
acquisition report the retention report
and the churn the cancellation of all so
let's look at them already quickly
the acquisition report builds on the
wonderful funnels that Tamsin showed
earlier but now it's a funnel that's
tailored especially for your business so
not only can you see which of your
channels drive the largest number of
installs but you'll see which drive the
largest number of free trial is at which
of your acquisition channels eventually
drive the largest number of high-value
repeat paying subscribers if you care
about putting your money and your effort
into the channels that give you the
highest value users on subscriptions
this is the report for you
secondly there's a retention report this
powerful new report allows you to
compare different cohorts from different
subscriptions so if you've got a brand
new sub that you're experimenting with
and you want to see if outperforms your
others you can quickly and easily plot
it and make that decision to make it the
primary one that you sell or if you try
to use some of our advanced features
like introductory pricing for instance
that you can see here the impact that
has on your burn down this is a really
really good place to inform your product
decisions to increase your attention and
lastly there's the term of all so let's
be honest when someone cancels your
subscription it sucks but this report
rocks and the reason I love this report
is because for the first time on the
play console you can see the exact days
that people choose to cancel your
subscription this means that you can
start seeing the impacts of that release
that you made to try to lower your
cancellation rates or you can use this
to start building a business model
behind that feature that you think is
going to keep people around for longer
taken together these three reports and
the dashboard give you a view into your
subs business that you have never been
able to have on the play console before
but we know that the insights you derive
from these are only the beginning of the
story because those insights drive your
decisions and those decisions drive what
tools you choose to use so I'm also
really happy to say that this IO we're
announcing a brand new tool called a
count hold this will allow you to know
when a user's payment has failed which
is one of the leading causes of
subscription cancellation at that point
account hold will let you withdraw the
entitlement of your great content in
your app and tell the user why you can
say hey there's been a problem with your
payments go into play and fix it and the
usual have 30 days to fix their payment
earlier we've been working with trusted
testers and trying this feature out and
we've seen a 25% increase in retention
rates so account hold and the new
subscriptions dashboard are just two of
the many features that teams across
Google are creating to help you guys
build successful businesses now
hopefully that's whetted your appetite
so if you want to know more I really
encourage you to come along to stage one
tomorrow at 10:30 to join me and a
couple of colleagues as we really delve
deeply into how to make more money using
subscriptions on Google Play so with
that I'd like to invite back to the
stage Panama a mapped around the session
al thank you very much
thanks Tom so much new stuff so in
addition to making use of the sessions
please do go online to gto / play /
developers you could read much more
about all of this new stuff there and
also think about who else in your
organization can become a user of the
play console and also if you haven't
already I do encourage you to download
the PlayBook app we've released a new
beta with a whole lot of new content
it's a great way to stay informed of all
of our announcements our blogs and other
great content to understand the features
all right so hopefully that has vetted
your appetite to try to build amazing
apps and games and I hope to see you
this evening at the Google Play Awards
at 6:30 where we are celebrating all the
wonderful work that has happened over
the last year I want to thank you for
challenging us to continuously innovate
for adopting the features that we invest
in and creating things that actually
provide superpowers to your users so
thank you very much for being here and
hope to see you at the Google Play award
[Applause]
[Music]
you